hello welcome to the debate on Sky News
I'm Martin Stanford here's our take on
developments brought together from
America the UK and around the world the
Paris attacks fighting terrorists is the
world now United France Russia and
America ramp up their bombing campaign
against Islamic state and the tourist
jet out of Egypt was blown up what can
the Middle East countries do now
so far this year there have been almost
300 terrorist attacks around the world
this month alone there have been 20
stabbings shootings and bombings
wikipedia lists them all here in their
list of terrorist incidents which
depressingly goes on and on the kill
list is now some 300 people now in a
moment we'll be speaking to the Egyptian
ambassador in London who's also served
in Paris but as usual the Democrat
commentator Geoffrey Robinson is
standing by for us in New York and the
conservative commentator Armstrong
Williams is in Washington Jeffrey what a
depressing week absolutely it really is
and it drove this thing home one of the
things that John Kerry said this week in
Paris was that he could almost
understand that there was some sort of a
what rationale for the the attack a year
ago on the satirical magazine but
killing innocent civilians like this is
just important and making it all the
more important making it all the more
insidious is the fact that most of the
most of the ISIS terrorists were
homegrown they come from France and
Belgium and once they're a cancer inside
society it takes a lot of operating to
get rid of it this is a really very
dangerous and tragic situation Armstrong
prisons have been saying all week why us
why Paris do you have a theory as to why
Paris you know I was when I was
returning from the airport last week
after being in London for a week our
private driver I expressed to him the
devastation of what happened in Paris
and without thinking he just turned to
us and said they got what they deserved
they are not very warm to people like us
they're very hostile and Germany is the
same way and it's just a matter of time
before it happens in Germany and 18 just
kept pulling my arm making sure that I
just did not go off on this guy and the
calm so angry by what he said then I
asked about what about
what your government was the reason for
that he was so matter-of-fact of a
people of his faith and its culture that
hatred of the Parisians and the Germans
and so to answer that question is that
what is lurking in Europe that no one is
talking about is the perception that as
much as parents more than anyone else in
your try to do to be supportive of these
refugees to be supportive of the Muslims
this will be supportive of people who
are not necessarily of their culture of
their faith the more resentment because
they talk about the poverty they talk
about the isolation they talk about
living in and thriving and ghettos and
they get no attention what the press
prints and what they say gives them a
little um a little momentum to their
plight but it doesn't even scratch the
surface and he felt that this was the
only way that they could lash out and
they say that this to us total strangers
having no idea what we would do we do
for living was nothing more than just
absolutely shocking well we work with
you two guys in a moment but first Egypt
was targeted directly by desh when it
was shot down a holiday jet this month
so what can the Arab states do will let
speak to NASA camel who's the Egyptian
ambassador in London and before that
served in Paris too let's talk about the
metrojet if we may is this an
embarrassment for Egypt do you think
that the security at Sharm el-sheikh was
such that this bomb could be planted on
this plane I don't want to get into
early conclusion about the how and
exactly what happened of course there is
some strong indication that it was a
bomb on this plane but we're waiting
always for the final conclusion of the
international panel that is
investigating this incident called
thoroughly but you are right when you
say Egypt has been targeted by dash beat
this horrific incident or or others
before I do agree with your guests when
we are talking about the cancer and
about the need to deal with that cancer
and
I don't think we are and it's not only a
fight that the Arabs or the Muslim
should carry alone this is a global
fight where we all have to come together
to deal with it and when I say to deal
with it we have to deal with it by
security definitely but also by anti
messaging by counter narrative by making
sure that young Muslims in Europe or
everywhere in the world are not subject
to it is sick propaganda that has
nothing to do with the true teaching of
Islam but what can you do with in your
country or what would you advocate your
country and then let's widen it out what
could the Arab world do to try and quiet
and down if not silenced the ISIL
message the dash message actually my
president was quite straightforward when
he dared even if the Islamic scholars in
Egypt and all over the world to deal
with the discourse in the and the
religious teaching and and and the way
our religion is being presented taught
and to two young Muslims all over the
world there is a certain discourse we
need to deal with it using institution
like al-azhar which is a moderate
Islamic center of learning to teach the
true value of that religion a religion
of peace elysian that definitely cannot
be undignified with those who have
carried the attacks in Paris the other
day let's bring in Armstrong and Jeffrey
first standing by New York will that fix
it Jeffrey just trying to sort out a bit
better teaching no I think the problem
is I think that's a good step and and
but the problem is much more complex and
and part of the problem now is the
Russians view about Assad they are
trying to keep him in power in Syria and
I think they take a view that it's I
they're Assad or ISIL and I and I think
it has to be a Asad and ISIL I don't
think I sudden and love to hear what the
ambassador says I don't think Assad is a
sideshow I think he's the main part of
this problem ambassador should President
Assad stay in power president asset is
definitely part of the problem there is
no argument about that and a political
solution in Syria would eventually lead
for a new leadership to emerge in that
country we need to be very clear I mean
the lingering of this drama in Syria has
been actually the reason for ISIL to
appear in the first place I mean the
stateless state where things are in
Syria has allowed those fanatics to
establish a foothold and then expand and
go all the way and control large parts
of Iraq so without a political solution
in Syria one that would reflect the
choice of the people one that would
bring to Syria a democratic secular
state that protects the rights and
freedom of all we won't be able to deal
with the problem definitely see let me
bring it on strong if I make assumption
that seems like a temptingly simple
solution so Syria and everything else
will come good is that really is it
really that simple well you know to make
that assumption you would have to
believe that all these ghastly attacks
are I've got their momentum and start
with Syria much of this was happening in
lonely for there's elva conflict in
Syria and I think this issue of social
media what Isis have become very yeah
yeah at recruiting young people who they
found that they can pour in this this
war philosophy and these ideas and get
them to lose lead places like the United
States and other places but they think
they can come for a better place and
then they manipulate them even further
to recruit their friends to come and
join Isis
you gotta find a way to disrupt those
agar-agar rhythms which we have access
to because one of the things that we
learned from the French ambassador
Campbell is that within minutes they
knew who the terrorists were they knew
their profiles they knew their cell
phone numbers they did not gather that
information all of a sudden after those
attacks it tells us they had been
tracking those people for a very long
time and they are what we would call
suspicious there's got to be a way that
governments and law enforcement act in a
way to take out these terrorists which
they think they have a pretty solid idea
in a case that about to commit these
kinds of acts that will kill hundreds of
people I know a president who lon talked
about revisiting the Constitution
there's been discussions about
revisiting habeas corpus we certainly
don't want to unleash people to go out
and sass innate and harm innocent people
but there's got to be a wetter way that
not just tracking these would-be
criminals given their track record that
we've got to be able to do something to
disrupt them before they commit these
crimes yeah but Armstrong hang on let
jeffry is nearly exploding here with the
idea if you've got a few suspects on a
list you're going to round them all up
and incarcerate them no I'm strong is
typically moving away from what the
discussion really isn't going off on
some tangent someplace what what the
ambassador was saying was that that
asset has to be dealt with and I want to
ask the Ambassador because I think the
reason a son has to be dealt with is
because the only people who can go after
ISIL the only people who can take this
calafat apart and it's the size of
Indiana are the Sunnis and as long as
Assad is in Syria the Sunnis are
otherwise preoccupied am i right in
saying that if we're going to ever have
troops on the ground boots on the ground
they have to be Sunni Muslims to do it
because the Americans are never going in
ambassador would you agree I agree that
the fight especially in Syria and Iraq
should be carried by the city and in the
Iraqi that is no doubt about it and
let's start with Iraq I mean we need to
empower the Sunni in here I'm
100-percent in agreement that the first
answer is to empower the Sunni in here I
give them a fair share
in their country make them a real
stakeholder in liberating their own
areas from from ISIL and the same
applies to Syria until we have a
political solution by which all the
Syrian will be united to fight ISIL we
won't be able to approve this disc
answer if I may say so from Syria and
Iraq I don't know in I just let me just
bring it on to the next question then
facing us all do we have to be fearful
whether we live in Paris or Frankfurt or
London as our prime minister said this
week we are still likely to be attacked
is that something we have to live with
is there anything we can do about that I
don't think anybody is immune in
unfortunately in today's world as long
as the ideology exists as long as you
open the internet and see guideline for
making a bomb and you see ISIL operating
on Twitter and when you talk to google
on others they seem to be powerless in
dealing with that propaganda I heard a
number i heard that ISIL is spending a
billion dollar a year in terms of
propaganda on the net and i'm talking
about the net and not the dark net until
we do lots of things anti messaging
solving Syria none of us unfortunately
is safe I'm strong that could be done I
mean you're a bit of a media mogul what
would you do to the media companies to
say to them we need to enforce their
messages or we need to take out the
messages that are getting to young
people of this destructive nature you
know I'm glad ambassador Campbell
understands the importance of social
media despite Jeffrey continuing often
to be out the lunch on the issues that
matter most you know we have an
obligation to shut them down we have an
obligation to monitor them we have an
obligation if we have the sense of them
we have a and monitoring them and the
activity follows a thread it a lot of
these things ambassador is absolutely
correct happens on these algorithms they
happen in this
space where we seem to allow them to do
a better job of spreading their
propaganda and we do very little to
challenge it we don't give enough
credibility that these young people find
most of those their contact their
connection the identification with these
groups that are very destructive with
the internet and until we Google and all
these Yahoo's of everybody else get on
board and all these different countries
and government gets on board to do a
better job a monitoring and following
the thread not much is going to change
that is something they've used to the
advantage and it's simple fussed by
taking a few simple measures to disrupt
it and turn it to our advantage state
censorship Jeffrey that's the answer no
no no no that the problem is
multifaceted the internet is only one
part of it but you see the neo-cons the
Republicans Armstrong in his mates and
of course the the king of them all of
ben Carson saying let's bomb them let's
find them we'll just bomb them bomb the
hell out of them and that'll do it will
put troops on the ground and that'll do
it and it will be and when we do it it
will be replaced by what that's the
problem is we can sure we can bomb them
and then why then we create a void this
is what the neo-cons armstrong and ben
Carson and all these guys did with their
rack originally you invaded Iraq Koppel
Hussein and now what we've got because
we created a void the problem is not
just the internet sure do what you can
on the internet but you've got to have a
sound policy and what you find now with
the Republicans is that a guy like Jeb
Bush is starting to understand that you
can't just bomb them into an intern on
existence that you've got to provide
something for afterwards that you've got
to take care of Assad in Syria and Jeb
Bush is starting to sound almost like
Hillary Clinton the next president of
the United States who will just do just
now let me let me say inclusion to put
that point to ambassador can i is there
a military solution can you bomb them to
submission ambassador multifaceted
approach one hundred percent i agree
with him hundred percent its we need to
use force if you have to at a certain
point at certain cases we need to take
care of the messaging we
we have 70,000 fatwa on the Internet
coming from ISIL every month that needs
to be dealt with we need to talk we need
to get our scholar to teach the true
value of this religion to young Muslim
in Islamic country and also in Europe
and in the United States multifaceted
approach we need to find a solution a
diplomatic one in Syria we need to
empower the Sunni in Iraq to be able to
face eyes in there there is no simple
answer unfortunately it has to be a very
complex and first of all we need to be
united and we need to come together and
look into the problem as an
international community and not leave
France alone or Egypt alone or the
Syrians alone and Buster NASA camel
thank you very much there are reminding
you can catch up with the Sky News
debate on apple TV on roku and catch up
and of course at Sky News com / us next
are the world's military and
intelligence communities now working in
harmony against daesh the islamic state
group well let's bring in Fred flights a
former CIA analyst and staff member with
the House Intelligence Committee now a
senior vice president at the center for
security policy I bet they're not all
working together Fred flights other I
mean the Russians and Americans don't
cooperate over anything that seems to be
the case it looks like the French and
the Russians are starting to collaborate
but the United States is refusing to
share intelligence with Russia because
it wants this diplomatic process to
bring about a new government in Syria
and the end the removal of Assad to move
forward frankly this is just a fig leaf
I think this is a thick leaf by the
Obama administration to do as little as
possible about this situation and French
president a lot is going to be talking
to President Obama to get him to change
that position but you've got to fix
something in Syria you can't do another
Iraq can you of destroy one part of a
country or one faction of a country or
one leadership in a country and leave a
vacuum behind afterwards I think the
Assad problem is a problem for another
a we need a Ground Force in Iraq and
Syria led by NATO with Arab troops to
take out Isis positions Isis is not
going to be defeated from the air and we
can't use these arguments about flooding
the Iraq war the Iraq Wars another war
we're now faced with a war against a
terrorist army if we don't take it out
the threat is just going to grow but the
lesson from the Iraq war wouldn't you
agree was the post-conflict planning we
can argue till the cows come home about
whether it was right to start the war
but after the war there was no country
left the infrastructure was destroyed no
wonder people got desperate you cannot
do the same thing again in Syria could
you I don't think the two situations are
analogous there was a sectarian conflict
going on in Iraq the situation in Syria
after we take Isis out is probably going
to be to the benefit of the Assad regime
I think that's probably an outcome that
is inevitable because a Russian support
for Assad it's not a great outcome but
we can't let this current situation of
this terrorist army to continue we have
to take Isis out Geoffrey Robinson is
standing by New York Armstrong Williams
as ever is in Boston for us Armstrong
get an army together and go and sort
these guys out is that the solution no I
agree wholeheartedly with i guess and i
think what he's not saying is that you
know what a special ops work there are
special forces that are more trained
more better at this they understand any
idiosyncrasies of these areas they have
contacts they work very different very
well with different arms of
intelligences of countries they know
more about these people then you can
imagine and sometimes what happens is
that laws of different countries of tata
hands and prohibit them from doing their
job at some point we're going to have to
take a look at some of these laws that
prohibit some of these agents and in
Special Ops of doing their job because
this crisis is growing the world is that
threat our stability and we just got to
give them the freedom to do what they do
best and put it in blunt turns what we
have to do we just have to turn out here
and close our eyes because we may not
like the way they do their business but
as long as they get the job done and
take these terrorists threats out
disrupt their financial networks
disruptive
the threads that they have in terms of
how they communicate eavesdropping on
them by any means necessary to destroy
them on every level until they're no
longer threat so if your prediction
Jeffrey is right and its president
clinton in a year's time would that be a
strategy she would adopt no no no she
was not adapter strategy we won't send
troops in because Isis wants nothing
more than to be able to go public with
look at that the West versus Islam I
mean it's just laid out there for them
if we do this you know this whole idea
you see it in the campaign now Donald
them and and all the others is a bomb
them but I just bombing back to the
Stone Age and Fred who comes from a
group run by Fred Frank Gaffney who part
of these neocon wackos who brought us or
the Iraq war remember weapons of mass
destruction didn't exist now the fact is
the fact is we can't bomb them because
we'll leave a void we did it in Iraq
we're not going to repeat that we need
to take Assad out at the same time when
we put Sunni troops on the ground
Islamic troops on the ground it's the
only way the ISIL will be defeated
american troops French troops Russian
troops just aren't going to do it fresh
you wanted to come in it would be
suicide I think that's just a fantasy
there's not going to be a Sunni force
going into Syria it would be nice i'd
like to see that but there's not going
to be a substantial force Syria in Iraq
unless it's led by NATO I think we have
to be realistic and the more we put this
on them for this terrorist right is
going to grow more more neocon wacko
conspiracy theories utter nonsense utter
clap track we stand on your record the
Iraq war you know I'm glares I have the
experts and some would like to say I a
who's worked on these issues who can
give us an impatient you're not
emotionalism the CIA give me a break
what's that in your clerk who works for
Frank Gaffney an Islamophobe hatred
mongering conspiracy mongering there
bunch of wackos come on they have no
credibility whatsoever I won't tell you
who sounds like the Y cool right now
yeah no credibility whatsoever no one
pays attention of these wackos we did
and that
what got us into a rack in the first
place okay well hang on let me let me
just step in here and ask question of
Fred seeing us we we've got him as our
guest this afternoon how are you going
to put the coalition together Fred
because the Iraq war as we know to only
too well here in the UK was a very
controversial political decision putting
that coalition together the UK the US
etc how are you going to put a coalition
together to deal with is on the ground
right now well I first want to defend
Frank Gaffney the Center for security
policy we have done important work on
the threat from the global jihad
movement and I encourage your your
viewers to go to our website secure
freedom gorg to see the important work
that we've been doing on this I mean
there is certainly intervention fatigue
in the United States and the UK no no
one in either country wants to send
troops to another medias conflict right
and I don't happen we have to avoid that
if we can but frankly the ISIS threat
has shown that France is at war with a
terrorist army and I'm afraid that
terrorist army is going to strike again
and we have to start thinking about
realistic ways to take it out they're
not going to be defeated by the air and
this idea of a total Sunni army it's
just a fantasy Jeffrey let's step aside
from the emotion of the specifics of the
strategy and last you to have a look at
the election seen as the presidential
election campaign for both sides rolls
on is this not going to impact on almost
all the candidates because there is a
sort of on one hand a demand for action
a demand to be safe on the other hand as
fred was saying there's a fatigue no
candidate let me put you the suggestion
can afford to recommend spending more
money in any country right now with
another military adventure they wish
they just get laughed out of town
wouldn't they no because that's exactly
what Ted Cruz is talking about exactly
what would ben Carson is talking about
send in Special Ops you know this is all
nonsense there there are real winners
and real losers politically in this
debate one of the winners is Donald
Trump and he has surged way ahead of ben
Carson in the latest polls he's beaten
Carson 38 1927 20 and 30 317 these are
the poles of this week where Carson is
disintegrating I mean watches interview
on fox news with chris wallace and
you'll see the real ben Carson come
he turned to rubble the other man who
was emerging as a the adult in the room
is Jeb Bush now I think he may be too
far behind to catch up but Jeb Bush this
is his opportunity if he doesn't take it
now I'm afraid the Donald will buy his
way into the cannon into the into the
primaries that the fact is that the
Republicans are very worried about
Donald and there are rumors now and I
believe them that they've gone to MIT
Romney and said we're going to bring you
back from the dead I don't know if
Romney would do it well okay let's see
that's a little side street we can go
down some other time but let me just
keep it on the fight against Islamic
state and let me put a final thought to
Fred if I may Fred flights the
difficulty your country faces is that I
suppose it's one step removed it's the
Atlantic Ocean removed from the events
of this last week and I don't mean to
sound cheapen the suffering of the
French and any sense but do you fear
that it will take another terrible event
on American soil really to galvanize
American politicians to take real action
I'm fearful that's going to be the case
both in Europe or the United States I
think that this group that was just
taken out in San Denis was planning
additional terrorist attacks in Europe
maybe in the UK maybe in France made me
in Germany I think it's very possible
there could be an attack like this in
the United States there's 900 open
isis-related investigations going on
right now according to the Department of
Homeland Security I think it could
change our outlook let's just pray this
doesn't happen Fred flights thanks for
being with us today and that's it for
this edition of the debate you can
continue watching sky news on apple TV
on roku and catch up and of course at
Sky News calm until next time goodbye
you
you